vous rappelez tous dali qui était venu
nous voir aller à licques et là il y
avait été traîné par des jeunes
voilà vous avez vu des images qui était
au mali vient de nous quitter on appris
ça par hocine son neveu voilà c'est est
due aux médicaments qu'il prenait pour
voilà calmer la douleur il est mort d'un
arrêt cardiaque c'est vrai que ça nous
fait mal on n'essaie pas aussi ne
viendra nous voir certainement lundi ça
nous fait tous énormément de peine 1
voilà je vois mathieu kérékou et le bon
j'espère vraiment dur un châtiment
exemplaire pour ceux qui l'ont traîné
casse de voitures
sauvage qui ce qui les sauve asile où
les racks et bouleversant et son
témoignage a été à la fois déchirant et
puis c'est cet optimiste et c'est cette
joie labonté qui est là mais ses
volontés roi cc c'est bouleversant
effectivement il faut que la justice
les coupables et sévices durement
durement et si vraiment vous que la
violence est surprenant durement balbir
du roi tuchel sont très touché parce que
c'est vrai que c'est un peu un plus il
voulait juste être tranquille il n'y
avait pas de haine je me souviens il
avait été très sinon voilà c'est non
c'est un sdf on propose ici des reines
et rois de connard en voiture qui enfin
je vous raconte tout perso mais qui n'a
rien à voir mais même à grande tante
avait 96 ans tire 20 20 20 euros à la
tirette il ya deux mecs qu'ils
l'emmenaient qui l'ont fait tomber par
terre à 96 ans tombé par terre et se
casser quelque chose c'est mourir
mais ces deux types si je devais
retrouver j'aurais pu rouler dessus en
bagnole faire tomber une femme de 96 ans
pour 20 euros mais au moins au moins les
grands voyous de l'époque je sais pas je
vais pas vous dire attaque et bourrin
brink's où n'importe quoi mais mais mais
mais s'attaquent à des sdf qu'il faut
traîner c'est la méchanceté pure quitter
ce qui peut se passer dans la tête que
de faire que de traîner un homme par
terre alors ils n'étaient pas des
fanions
une baleine cigarettes le traînant
animalista mais colas qui était connue
partout dans paris fils
le match
n'avait il avait son petit appart son
truc il voulait juste lui qu'est ce
qu'ils ont dans la tête ces trois
gens-là ce courage là bas si cela je
peux vous dire c'est comme la fille qui
était tombé tête de de son balcon et on
a dit que le mec était soit disant pour
l'antisémisme et que le type finalement
en fait elle était fut été feu qui n'a
pas été jugé si ces trois personnes là
y'a pas un châtiment exemplaire je
comprends plus rien ce pays ce serait
une honte totale une révolte y va
on va revenir 60 à faire bien entendu
lundi eux aussi ne sera avec nous je
pensais va rendre hommage à ali qu'on
ait eu beaucoup en plus